hey guys it's max I hope you guys are
all doing well in this video I'm gonna
be taking a look at the latest firmware
for the s20 ultra and seeing if Samsung
finally fixed the cameras on this
high-end expensive smartphone I'm
actually recording with it right now and
I'm not only gonna be comparing it to
the previous firmware but I'm also gonna
throw in a few comparison shots with my
iPhone 11 Pro just to see how they
compare with the latest firmware fix
starting off with the previous firmware
you see it takes a while to switch focus
and then when it does it's very harsh
it's not smooth it's almost like it's
changing in steps and even when it does
lock on as soon as she stands up it goes
out of focus again back and focus back
out of focus it's not smooth whatsoever
you don't want this in your videos and
here we have the firmware update you see
it's switched pretty quick and it looks
to be a little bit smoother as well and
there it actually didn't lock into focus
and then it's switched back right there
so definitely we're seeing some
improvement it's not focus hunting as
much and it might be a little smoother
but we're still seeing some of that
stepping and here we have them side by
side for you guys to be able to compare
back and forth
the focus transition is quicker we have
less hunting but if we look at the top
left corner of the after the latest
firmware you still see that kind of
stepping especially when it's focusing
closer but overall it is a welcome
improvement and now let's add in its
biggest competitor and the iPhone and
you see even with the firmware update it
cannot compete with the iPhone neither
one is instantly switching picking up my
daughter's face its switching back
quickly super smoothly no jerkiness no
stuttering none of that it is doing an
excellent job now let's look at some
photos this is what the old firmware the
first shot was in focus with my daughter
on the swing second one out of focus
third one also out of focus fourth one
out of focus again fifth one is out of
focus
sixth even worse and the seventh shot
finally it got it in focus again so to
seven shots were in focus on the swing
and now on the right side I have the
latest firmware and you see it is out of
focus on the first shot but it took a
picture earlier same thing with the
second shot and then we go into the
third shot it is also out of focus and
that was getting me worried and then
another out-of-focus shot and then the
fifth one here it actually is in focus
but it took the picture it later took
longer to focus before it snapped a
photo same thing for the sixth one is in
focus and also the seventh one so it
looks like three out of seven were in
focus and now let's see how the iPhone
did do you guys can see it's much closer
even though I'm taking a picture at the
same time the iPhone has much less
shutter lag so there's kind of the best
scenario which was actually using before
firmware and I'm pressing it as soon as
she's the closest to me so let's just
take a look at the series of iPhone shot
so this one is in focus here this shot
her face out of focus but they got the
hair on top was actually little bit
closer to me this shot right here this
one's slightly out of focus on the face
but she's much closer this shots in
focus the next shot was in focus and
that one is in focus and this one's in
focus as well so the shutter lag is
maybe a quarter of the lag of the s20
and the focus is much better this is
using the telephoto and I just screen
recorded to show you the performance of
the focusing and they'll sometimes miss
focus sometimes they'll just take too
long sometimes it'll lock on like that
and then sometimes will just miss focus
and they'll just allow you to take the
photo without it being in focus and now
with the latest firmware you guys could
see I actually miss focus on the lens
there but it was faster focused on the
camera there and then going back looks
like it got it let's try one more time
okay not bad definitely looks like we do
have some improvements still a little
bit of hunting and it's not sure where
to focus on but definitely better and
now tracking my son at 4k 60 did to the
front to the back to face back again
and then it finally locked on and then
afterwards looks to be doing okay a
little bit smoother there and then it
kind of misses his face at first in the
background and then it locks on and then
looking at the iPhone first off the
actual quality looks way better we have
a nice smooth transition he gets way
closer but it locks onto his face in his
hair and here's just another side by
side so that's 20 did get a bit better
as far as the focus hunting but it still
has a ways to go so there you guys have
it let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below
did Samsung do enough was this fixed
enough to make you consider buying one
of these ultras or is it not enough is
it too late I want to hear your guys's
opinions
also if you want to see a comparison
against the iPhone as far as maybe
photos some night shots with the latest
firmware on the s20 ultra to see if
there's any image quality differences or
any other fixes let me know down below
and hit that thumbs up button and maybe
we'll consider making another one if you
guys want to see more videos click that
little circle above and then if you want
to see a couple great videos we have
some right over there on the side thanks
for watching this with Max and I will
see you in the next one
[Music]